near the Arctic Circle in Siberia is the
world's coldest permanently inhabited
town its residents deserve our respect
and our sympathies for Minnesota so I
know cold but it is nothing on the level
of what the residents of the Wakhan have
to deal with so for six months out of
the year from October to March the
temperature is always below freezing to
give you some perspective the average
temperatures in January are equivalent
to the temperatures on Mars the coldest
temperature ever recorded there was a
negative 90 I don't know what happens at
negative 90 I imagine that that you just
die you go outside you just instantly
die it has to be negative
60 degrees before they tell the kids to
stay home from school this creates all
kinds of strange problems they have to
leave their cars idling batteries just
immediately die electronics in general
are basically useless the air is
actually sucking the moisture out of
your body when someone dies in or makaan
during the winter they have to light a
bonfire let it burn for half a day dig
down about a foot and do the same thing
over it can take days on the plus side
all it takes to refrigerate your food is
a basement then they just throw your
carcasses down there they eat a lot of
frozen meat go to snacks are cubes of
frozen reindeer blood and thinly sliced
reindeer or horse meat what do the
people of oina con do for fun besides
drinking of which they do a fair amount
one of the things they do is participate
in something called the walrus Club
which involves finding a river in the
middle of winter and jumping into it and
I think the parts that is fun is that
you don't die so from a man who grew up
in the world's third the coldest place
to the residence of the world's first
coldest place Vash Estero via
subscribe here and watch more videos
here we used to do this thing where you
could take a cup of boiling water throw
the boiling water into the air and it
would never hit the ground it would just
disappear into a puff of steam it would
sort of sublimate into the air that was
awesome that's a great thing to do when
it's really cold out
what are some other wonders that I
should know about what do you want to
hear me talk about what do you want to
tell me about what is the greatest place
you've ever been I want to know all
these things